[Music]
since the beginning
halo was about master chief and cortana
partners protecting humanity
but that is now a distant
memory humanity is fighting for survival
the banished have risen defeated our
heroes
and taken control of the mysterious zeta
halo
we need a savior
we need hope
we need spartan 117 master chief
[Music]
we have a new mission soldier what is it
what's down there a weapon
a weapon
how many guns do you need
in the biggest campaign to date halo
infinite invites players to become
master chief and discover true spartan
freedom in the most wide open and
adventure-filled halo experience yet
but chief won't be alone on the journey
his first mission is to retrieve a new
ai codenamed the weapon
it's been six months where have you been
following the events of halo 5 master
chief is searching for the answer to a
troubling question
what happened to cortana
i was created to lock down cortana but i
don't know why
what did she do that was so wrong
the answer is somewhere on zeta halo
a damaged world full of wonder mystery
and danger
and at every turn
the banished our hunting master chief
and the remnants of the unsc victory
the banished army is spread across the
surface
building fearsome strongholds and
outposts with no one to stop them
until now
from the beginning of the halo saga
master chief has been a hero ready to
fight and win against impossible odds
chief is that you you're safe now
incoming but
what if it's a friend
it isn't
players now have more freedom than ever
before to take down the banished any way
they choose
spanish facility up ahead chief
some kind of salvage operation
what do we do
shut it down
permanently
well
what do we have here
do you see that could be useful
if you like that kind of thing
oh i like it
halo infinite allows us all to become
master chief doing what spartans do best
defying the odds to take down the
banished
piece by piece
this won't be an easy fight
master chief will take on returning
favorites
and surprising new threats like the
agile skimmers
a sadistic spartan killer named jega or
domini
look out chief he looks angry and
something even more threatening
the forerunners lies are at an end
i am the harbinger of the truth you are
not the future
exploring this vast and fractured world
will put spartan 117 to the ultimate
test
but where there is courage
there is hope
welcome to the new era of halo
is everyone trying to kill you
it kinda seems like it
[Music]
play it day one with game pass